le ministre de l'économie pierre
fitzgibbon a présenté les annonces de
jeudi chez bombardier com et à de bonnes
nouvelles
vendre des parts donc de bombardier dans
la 220 à airbus cession de parts
également au gouvernement du québec
mais une chute quand même de près de 50%
de la valeur de l'investissement du
gouvernement du québec dans le programme
on vous propose ce soir l'analyse
d'isabelle dostaler spécialisé dans
l'aérospatiale qui est doyenne de la
faculté d'administration des affaires à
l'université memorial à terre neuve
zabel dostaler bonsoir bonsoir qu'est ce
que vous pensez de ce qui a été annoncé
jeudi est ce qu'on peut quelque part
s'en réjouir c'est quand même assez
triste tout ça moi je reviens toujours
avec cette idée que ce pays
collectivement réussi à développer
l'avion commercial le plus avancé à ce
jour dont les performances techniques
sont au delà de ce qu'on espérait on
sait c'est vraiment un appareil le
moteur de cet appareil est la structure
ont été inventée ensemble ont été mariés
ensemble et ça fait ça fait des bonnes
performances en apparaît très silencieux
les économies de carburant et cédera
donc on doit être fier de tout ça ce qui
est absolument très sais que c'est pas
nous qui allons vendre cet appareil
simplement qu'il a mari s'appelle
maintenant à 220 c rien de très
réjouissant
cependant c'est ce que l'arrivée d'un
géant comme airbus dans le dossier on
comprend bien que c'est toujours
difficile de connaître l'avenir de
pouvoir garantir que tout va bien se
dérouler par contre un bus et un joueur
sérieux et surtout un joueur avec lequel
les grands transporteurs aériens qui
seront les clients de la 220 sont
habitués de transiger c'est sécurisant
d'acheter un nouvel avion d'airbus
plutôt que de bons mardy est un joueur
finalement assez inconnu pour ceux qu'on
appelle les médias des très grands
transporteurs aériens
donc quelque part où c'est au bout du
compte 6 7 avions
ça va être le succès qu'on pense que ça
peut être et que les emplois sont
préservés et que surtout tous nos
fournisseurs aérospatiale au québec
ailleurs au canada
si le programme fonctionne
ils ont ils ont des clients à qui vendre
leurs produits et services allant faut
pas oublier non plus toute cette mort
apéro spatiale contre le real mais qu on
a aussi des expertises d'un bout à
l'autre
mais ce que le premier ministre legault
a raison de dire que bombardier n'aurait
jamais dû se lancer finalement dans
l'aviation commerciale qui avait trop de
gros concurrents
non moi je pense que c'est cesser ces
sons qu'elle le premier ministre le goût
est un peu pris dans sa rhétorique
notamment quand il raconte que ce
n'était pas une bonne idée d'investir
jugeant la cseries de la part du
gouvernement il ya quelques années plus
tôt que dans bombardier de façon
générale non le problème c'est pas
d'avoir de s'être
attaquée à ce projet de la série c'est
d'avoir voulu faire trop de choses en
même temps qu'on développe et la cseries
ont développé aussi deux avions
d'affaires le lieu 85 et le global 7000
500 s'était beaucoup c'est quand même
c'est par rapport à l'échelle mondiale
par voir les géants comme airbus et
boeing bombardier est un petit joueur
alors que sept petites entreprises
prennent sur elle de mener de front ces
trois projets là c'était énorme c'était
trop ambitieux et avait peut-être une
forme de naïveté également là dedans
bon c'est sûr que ce sont des décisions
qui ont été prises avant l'arrivée dans
les bêlements je pense pas qu'on aurait
mieux fait que lui à la barre de
l'organisation il ya toute la question
aussi de l'entreprise familiale moi je
pense que joseph armand beaudoin a été
un journal invente roumanie pendant
qu'elle là dessus il était cet inventeur
sa fille épouse laurent beaudoin qui lui
s'est avéré être un génie c'est lui qui
a vraiment mis de l'avant cette
stratégie de croissance qui a été
absolument extraordinaire et cette
décision de prendre les avions
d'affaires font d'amendé et l'a allongée
et le créer l'industrie du jet régional
quand même extraordinaire que cette
petite entreprise est contribué à créer
une toute nouvelle industrie alors mais
là mon fils quoi cette entreprise mais
de deep roquettes comme on dit en
anglais c'est sûr que quand on est un
plus petit joueur on a on n'a pas autant
d'argent que les boeing et airbus est là
c'est sûr qu'on entend toujours un peu
de bombardier bashing à travers le pays
puis bon on en veut on est choqué que de
l'argent j'espère de taxer été investis
dans les programmes etc
mais c'est tout d'abord quand on a
développé le crj le 50 places le
gouvernement fédéral a investi dans ce
programme est il rentré dans son
investissement
plusieurs fois parce qu'on a vraiment
vendu de ce produit comme des petits
pains prenez boeing en ce moment aux
états unis jacobins sa part de problèmes
avec le max 8 qui est vraiment une
catastrophe
boeing continue à faire la moitié de son
chiffre d'affaires avec des contrats
militaires le secteur militaire c'est
beaucoup plus près visé
l'aviation commerciale pensez vous que
le gouvernement américain va laisser
tomber boeing jamais je me les rebus les
parties sud ads ckoi ads un groupement
d'intérêt économique sont alors vraiment
des pays européens ce sont qui se sont
mis en partenariat pour littéralement
compétitionner avec les états unis avec
l'aérospatiale à ce niveau là ça se joue
c'est de la compétition entre pays
donc c'est inévitable d'avoir l'aide de
l'état mais ici c'est tellement un sujet
chargé de puisque il ya la famille
bombardier beaudoin qui bon c'est très
très bien eux mêmes leur épingle du jeu
c'est sûr que c'est frustrant d'avoir
bon cette famille particulièrement bien
nantis et la de savoir que bon des
données publiques ont été investis et
mais à long terme moi je pense que c'est
ce qui c'est ce qu'on devait faire
dernier point est ce qu il est clair que
l'avenir de bombardier donc dans les
avions d'affaires et que ça ça va
marcher
c'est rien n'est moins claire férus du
ballon
well on attend de voir ce qui va se
passer ce côté des traits le problème du
secteur de l'avion d'affaires en ce
moment c'est que trop de joueurs alors
on a quatre autres compétiteurs autres
bombardiers lesquels ont tout soit dit
en passant des bras militaire donc ils
sont un peu dans la situation comme
boeing ou ils ont une partie de l'offre
de leurs portefeuilles d'activités qui
leur assure des revenus
le problème en ce moment c'est qu'il ya
trop de produits sont comparables dans
tous les produits sont disponibles sur
le marché dans le domaine de l'avion
d'affaires est ce que les marchés mais
amir qui aimeraient voir c'est ce qu'on
appelle en anglais price de ce que l'on
aimerait voir de la consolidation dans
l'industrie pour que moins de gens moins
de joueurs moins de produits sitex krang
faisait l'acquisition en traitaient sol
bleu
la rumeur est expect ne pourrait plus
faire l'acquisition du portefeuille de
jeff corporatif de bombardier ou de jets
d'affaires s'arrête permis à textron de
nettoyer un peu leur gamme de produits
et ça aurait peut-être été bon pour
moyens parce qu'à fort à parier que
c'est davantage les produits
fabriqué à wichita qui aurait
probablement plus souffert davantage
d'une consolidation
lorsque oublions pas que le joyau de la
couronne dans le domaine des avions
d'affaires c'est vraiment le global 7500
c'est un avion avec une portée
incroyable mais c'est quand même une
industrie difficile en ce moment parce
qu'il ya trop de joueurs
merci beaucoup il abaisse dostaler
c'était passionnant cette analyse merci
ça m'a fait plaisir merci